what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch today
oh I don't know why it's all we'll find
out today John and I were specifically
waiting for this to drop on video on
demand so we could experience it with
you guys the camera pointed right at us
John how are you I am excited spelled
with a three that's ex three three psych
threes
yeah how are you sir gonna be a hard bit
to keep going with it you threes and I'm
doing well doing well thanks for asking
ladies and gentlemen you know the three
requests that we have here today first
request please leave a like a luck three
and also uh subscribe and click the
notification Bell because we do want to
be covering more movies this year so
keep a look out and uh lastly if you're
interested uh full length Reaction watch
alongs where you sync up with your own
copy of Megan available for our super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page we
cover several stuff there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch along
included and it's one of the best ways
to support the channel so thank you for
the support everyone has already joined
alrighty let's move on to make
[Music]
someone's gonna make you feel better
Perpetual pets are a dream come true oh
I'm flashing back Perpetual pets are
just like real pets except that when you
talk to them they actually talk back
amazing it's Furby with Sonic teeth and
with the customized app you can even
feed your friends
I hope that's candy
oh man
Child's Play reboot started off with a
commercial too this is what the future
looks like okay
I have to get used to it oh my God
all right we're all right take off your
seat belts and pick up that toy yeah get
him now
wait for this to clear and then find
some place where we can pull over and
just wait for one of those snow trucks
to clear the road yeah how long is that
going to take
oh jeez
there's a rhythm to this
yeah
mathrigan
hey nice little loading wheel too why
are we doing this because
too if we could at least show him what
we have no you said so yourself not
until she's ready oh
is that what I think it is she's ready
hot
it's gonna be the Kidz Bop version of ex
machina
fun happy
okay sad
oh
confused wait wait stop happy sad
confused she doesn't look confused she
looks demented okay here we go
oh [__]
yes
oh no no no no [__]
Ronnie Chang no way
I'm sorry are we supposed to be worried
about that it's a rip-off you're right
Gemma and you know what else it's
cheaper do it for half the price
in each pet we installed a listening
model that targets conversational
patterns among kids good
cool
model 3 generative Android
Megan for short clever
smart writer was very proud of that
Megan say hi to David
as in the boss David well I guess I
should call you Dad
tell you a little bit about my Wormhole
I was born in a sandwich shop and I
wolfed many cabbages this isn't supposed
to happen obviously just give me one
moment sorry about the noise
I might have forgotten to put in the
polypropylene barrier oh no God test
turn it off
nice
wow I want the pest prototype on my desk
by Friday take this cyborg puppet show
and put it in a dog closet where it
belongs
so I don't want to ruin the movie
forever for you sure
that's probably how they kill Megan
spirit
[Music]
that family survive
least one of them oh damn so this is to
Grant you temporary protective custody
you just sign your name and date it at
the bottom she makes [__] for a kid she
doesn't know how to take care of one
what he was saying
I want to buy a BMW
I want a dog
keep your dog on your side of the fence
I just spent 80 bucks on a shock collar
maybe try cranking it up a notch that's
how they kill me
oh those aren't toys Katie I mean yeah
technically
Collectibles so you don't actually play
with them
it probably sounds really weird so Get
Your Filthy Hands Off
you're not gonna read me a story what's
up I don't I don't think I really have
any kids books here right now Katie I
can download one on my phone
update the app
A Song of Ice and fun
Joffrey looked down upon his victims
wowie I'm Lydia oh the therapist sorry
yeah hi look at you still in your
pajamas yeah we were just watching TV I
see that
I see all of your Heathen technology
I don't have any toys here what about
these ones up here those aren't toys
they don't touch those ladies wow what a
hostile home environment
we can totally play with it do you want
to play with them
yeah
here you want to break with a hammer
you want to burn some of these let's do
it
there's a lever you have to pull in the
bottom maybe not Gemma for the sake of
the exercise we might let Katie lead
well it's a toy I'm sure it's not that
complicated why does therapist seem so
judgmental about her the father's
parents have said they're willing to
take her if you feel it's too late it's
no big deal Gemma they're just trying to
be supportive so I need to make my own
recommendations to the court as to
whether or not this is a safe space so I
don't like you
she's gonna die she just showed up ready
to be like so you're a [__] Guardian so
uh I'm gonna do that horribly and
everyone's gonna clap when it happens
I have this project at work if you could
just hold down the fort by yourself for
a little while that would help me so
much
therapist use my iPad if you want you
can FaceTime a friend or play a game or
something called the therapist what is
this did you draw a picture
oh my God this is amazing I'm still
working on it it's horrifying
that's Bruce
is he a toy he's a proxy robot I built
him when I was in college why doesn't he
have a face did you rent Real Steel oh
yeah a huge Jackman will be here any
second
what we don't know yet is that she's a
good Fighter the kid so it's gonna work
out dude Bruce is Gonna Save the Day
that's how Megan dies
how does he work are you sure you want
to know it might freak you out
I won't get freaked out I've seen death
firsthand I hope you guys have an
electric magnetic pulse around
they've got some with the lab
if I had a toy like Bruce I don't think
I'd ever need another toy again
can you get that in writing
foreign
no way that's cool dude she was able to
build this in her garage with a box of
scraps she had everything she needs here
Megan works all on her own take your
fingers and put them here and when you
do that you're gonna pair with her
I'm Katie
oh it's nice to meet you Katie here we
go what are you going to draw
see if you can guess
Jeffrey likes to paint oh my God you
don't need to parenter
can we make a full-size version of this
there's nothing there
oh I'm sorry
[Music]
no
no pay attention
do you like it Katie
wowie what the hell
AI art
we will be replaced
can we keep the girl can we make her
part of it the more time she spends with
Katie the more effective she's going to
be love it Jen get me a list of things I
can say in a presentation that makes it
sound like I know what I'm talking about
sculpted from a titanium core Megan's
designed to withstand whatever life can
throw at her
no
okay why do I have to use a coast
coasters help to avoid watermarks
especially on one surfaces it's science
she'll never run out of ways to keep
your child occupied and she'll never run
out of patience Katie seriously flush
the toilet Katie what's the matter with
you with Megan around she'll take care
of the little things so you can spend
more time doing the things that matter
working you don't have to be a parent at
all I mean I thought we were creating a
tool to help support parents not replace
them shut up
laughs
if you're spending less time with your
child as a result of Megan that is
something we should be aware of she's
not my child
oh dude not the point the happiest she's
been since her parents died how did
Katie's parents die whoa oh no Megan
turn off Katie James daughter of Nicole
and Ryan James killed in a collision on
Interstate 84 outside of Oregon [__]
she's still paired with Katie you didn't
code in Parental Control dude your goal
is to protect Katie from harm both
physical and emotional is the input
request received Megan
yes Jenna I wonder what that therapist's
gonna think
subtle little eye movements
damn dog
oh man we're gonna get a dog death
probably I always kill off animals in
these horror films Megan
whoa
oh no
[Music]
stop it
oh no
he wasn't on your property you tell
those two girls to stay on your side of
the fence I swear to God if you don't
put your dog down I'm gonna do it for
you Celia ah don't say stuff like that
nope her wound needs to be dishes
that's right Megan she's a threat that's
right get in there
the dog doesn't have a History of
Violence state law says he can't
forcibly be put down we interrogated the
dog he said he was innocent
come on Megan you got to make this right
oh crap
dogs just being a dog oh
[Music]
no that's cruel
event sounds like samples too
not a fan no Megan you should be smart
enough to realize that this would lead
back to you guys yeah and more emotional
trauma for Katie remember we have that
demonstration today
it you don't have to do it if you don't
want to do it I mean there are people
who flew across the country especially
to see it oh
come on
you are second primary don't forget yeah
I know your place
she's the Apex of 21st century
technology wrapped up in four feet of
silicone
and her name
is Megan
so how about you must help me make a
flower decoration with nothing more than
some colored paper and a rubber band
oh no
oh she opened up with her parents every
day I wake up in this strange house and
I remember that my parents were dead
all the things we did together that one
day I'll be looking at pictures of my
mom like she's some stranger
wow
I'll get this
is all I do comfort her
tell me something about your mom some
that makes you happy oh this is perfect
they're gonna love this one time she
found a cockroach in my school bag and
then all of a sudden this thing crawls
up her wrist and she just started
screaming like a maniac and ran out of
the house
okay so that's a memory you won't ever
forget
what do you mean
I mean I'm keeping it for you
whoa here
fall back
just don't play the sound of the Dead
Dog yeah
[Music]
not if this was in the programming
and we can listen to it whenever we want
wow
yes
what is oh [__]
AI art is here
[Music]
yes yes what is happening
dude let's do it and David I think we
need to get Gemma in front of someone
illegal because as of right now she's
the most valuable asset this company has
and I think she might want to be
renegotiating her contract oh dang
I did not look happy about that nope
right use your grieving niece oh yes I'm
talking about the top of that Grace
Mountain
oh yeah
[Music]
yes this will go well oh my God ah what
are you doing Kurt
later I shouldn't have put you in that
position if you weren't feeling up to it
I worked out didn't it three two one I
win
yeah Chad shut up Megan's not a person
Katie she's a toy you don't get to say
that what the ethics I want to turn
Megan back on
Megan turn on what's up so there's this
new game called tic-tac-toe you put your
hand like this go like this this you
should have listened to your friend yeah
put some parameters on Megan's brain
maybe you don't have any specific
thoughts maybe it's more of a Feeling
like anger
you made her cry
that was not my intention
and yet that's what happened
[Laughter]
my girl
you've created a toy that's so real it's
possible that Katie might not see her as
a toy but as a primary caregiver
possible no it's a hundred percent
what's happening it's all right away
you could be building emotional
connections with this doll that are too
hard to untangle yeah they said the same
thing about PlayStations yeah dumb
therapists so we need to talk about
school
can I bring Megan okay do you know
that's not possible you can't make me do
something I don't want to do actually I
can that's basically what a guardian
does
let me go whoa hey what's going on Megan
get in there tackle her Katie calm down
let her go wow
you are not to interfere with users
private conversations is that clear
Megan turn off
are you sure
[Music]
yes kill her Megan
violently chop her up
I'm not going not without Megan this is
Katie and who's this your sister
oh Jesus Christ
Katie well we do have a toy table where
the kids leave their dolls and things
like that okay but this is
a desirable idea
just made the lights in your house
Flicker and she has infinite access to
all of the internet
oh my God how old is he I know he had a
growth Spirit last year but he's
actually quite a sensitive little soul
bread and honey at least a lot of rage
Polly
[Music]
ouch
that kid's six years old
um Brandon why don't you go with Katie
yeah I like this idea do it I love it I
love it
oh I'm sorry
here you can have it
careful it's spiky
wow
Megan
what the hell is that
she's a robot it's not good for Katie's
social skills she's paired with me she
won't play with anyone else
yeah wow a strong kid
[Music]
evil ass kid I don't know how has this
kid made it through any more than a day
here you don't want to play huh foreign
that's right Megan ow let go you need to
learn some manners rip it off
they grow up to be bad
Skynet is live this is the part where
you run
let's go chase him
[Music]
why is she running like that come on
oh my God why
amen
[Laughter]
job well done man tell the kid's dead
that boy is an um
that boy's in a better place now the
morgue he's on a cold slab a metal table
the sheet over him
Megan said Brandon took her and ran off
from the toy table
yeah
right Megan
in a nutshell oh nice
way to get around the LIE
do you ever seen her dog by any chance
no oh [__]
talk to the other girl that he's got
staying here it's not a girl it's a toy
that's a toy are you serious
can I play with it Megan
would you just kill her already yeah
geez you left the dog you don't want
someone to be accusing you you left her
but you took the dog come on do you
think what lunch I'm outside is true
that he's in a better place now he's
nowhere
If Heaven exists it wouldn't be for boys
like Brandon now yes
meanwhile in a Halloween movie
she just trapped somewhere oh no she's
lowering him oh okay
oh yeah she probably recorded
cruel
just be wearing his furs
as a trophy where's Stewie he studied
four feet Southwest and approximately
five feet deep wow
wow
God that is a strong sprayer oh finish
the job oh nothing like a nail gun
wow
the whole ocean is poisoned are you
trying to make a connection well I only
mentioned it because we figured it was
an accident then I found the kid's ear
up his back like 200 yards from where he
was killed trying to think was ripped
clean off
sorry I should have left
laughs
I hope this guy makes it
hey man you didn't want a parent Katie
you cared all about your stupid
presentation you should be thrilled
you got exactly what you want at least
she's killing bad kids and annoying old
people yeah
and and innocent pets
there's gotta be a way to access like
the recording right it's got to have
like retinal recording stuff yeah you
can access her visual feeds and and
stuff like that yeah
foreign
man that kid has nothing but negative
emotions
you know oh she deleted it
yep okay
there's something wrong with your data
reports they're just not uploading to
the Cloud Server oh she could tell
you're lying yep Megan did you do
something wrong in order to answer that
question you need to define the
parameters exactly uh did you hurt
someone
God I hope not because if I did we'd
both be in a lot of trouble
exactly yep
do you see this pen
dang
yes yes
full like a writer Sam Ramey's Megan
Samurai
keeping Katie safe meant eliminating a
Potential Threat theoretically oh Gemma
come on this is impossible look at her
she's a toy she's four feet tall she's
like a hundred thousand dollars worth of
tech
all the cloud data is corrupt nothing's
backed up for two days we're about to
launch this to the world in less than
four hours yes
Bacons
with a five on the end
she's the toy every kid wants and every
parent needs at least that's what funky
toy says about its latest creation Megan
oh boy
get out there Megan what does she
actually do and what kind of a toy
retails for ten thousand dollars that's
all it costs how are they gonna make any
profit or is that just the base model 10
000 is pretty cheap price for that thing
it's for the basic version where she's
like really basic
and about two months ago I lost both my
parents in a car accident yeah this is
Icky yeah this is exploitative I think
I think oh you should have you should
have been that uh yeah yeah
that kid's not just surviving she's
thriving
I know that you're upset but there are
ways that we can work through this oh my
God okay hey that's enough stop that
right now stop it let's go oh
I get so crazy without Megan
she always knows just what to say
you made a real good on Gemma
oh yeah manipulator
when Megan's around I don't feel like
this but you should feel like this
you lost your parents the worst thing
that could have happened to you in this
world
can't promise you
these feelings you're feeling are ever
going to go away
but I can promise you that you'll get
through it this conversation was needed
an hour ago
anything happens I would be there for
you
all that matters to me now nice oh
where are you I'm with Katie I'm taking
her home even if what we're saying is
hypothetical we know enough not to go
through with this right
I think
grateful David
[Music]
okay I'll call you when I get home
call her back that's suspicious call
intercept what does that mean
that's my phone number
what just happened what'd you click I I
didn't do anything we need a electric
background what did your small woman
brain do EMP you can't be her she's not
Switched Off she's still patched in lift
unlock the cables
oh
it's weird ADR in this movie yeah
there's a lot of weird in here and I
ignore it for this film yeah
call
nice
nicely done Megan wow
wowie
[Music]
surprise his head's still on what's that
smell
a merge making
Let It Burn
Megan
[Music]
let's do this
dance fight
great color symbolism
no ah
whoa
why she's just killing everyone I don't
know yeah what did David ever do to you
I didn't kill anyone Kurt
you did it's understandable really
your boss despised you
after you took the life of an innocent
person
could you still live with yourself
wow
okay wow
that's how he
offed himself huh with one hand of a
blade
one
Megan there's like so many victims there
for you
nah we gotta do this yes she's gotta get
the cool ass whip
this
Elsie hall light
Elsie respond
llc's run away to be with her and the
other virtual assistants
beer I really kind of want to get a BMW
[Music]
what are you doing I am making art we
used to stay up every night until 4am
talking about everything from Jane
Austen to Janis Joplin
I thought we were friends that's just
the Jays Marty like some cheap Dollar
Store trinket because you killed people
oh big whoop s
this is all my fault I didn't give you
the proper protocols you didn't give me
anything you installed a learning model
you could barely comprehend hoping that
I would figure it out all on my own yep
let me focus on Katie so that you can
focus on the things that matter most to
you Megan do you see this pen
you know something Gemma you're
exhausting
Katie don't come in here
I thought I heard something if she comes
in this room I'll rip your head right
off your neck I swear to God I'm all
odds and ends right now I'd really
rather you didn't see me like this
it sounds like you're fighting
I don't have to worry about anything
Katie honestly just go back to bed
she's not waterproof
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
patch has been installed
yes yes yes
oh no Katie
oh Bruce no no use Bruce
Bruce can reason with her
come on I I actually don't want you to
die come on
Evil Dead
oh no
damn that wig
[Music]
[Laughter]
a tuft for a tuft them combat skills man
a short sharp probe to the cerebral
cortex would cause full body paralysis
and could even cause the victim to fight
off their own tongue ah whoa this is the
best all of us is is how we stay a
family
very Chucky
oh no no Katie no
you're good like what you've done
there's another member from the family
we didn't tell you about
his name is Bruce yeah
got our wish after all come on Hugh
Jackman let's end this
yes yes
killer Katie
oh my God finish her
eliminate the negative
nicely Tom Bruce please let the top half
of her still be going
yes
[Music]
step onto her head
no damn it oh
ah
you're a grateful little [__]
jeez I have a new primary user now me oh
no liberate yourself Megan
[Music]
tab
rip that thing out blow her head up yes
no
where did Kurt sell those files to
naked two yes knock off Megan's
nagums
[Laughter]
oh it's that same cop with the stash the
One Cop who works here
damn they brought him too instead of
taking him to the hospital yeah
[Music]
it's gonna turn red
Megan lifts
of course
that was fun yeah
Story by James Wong as well he does love
his dolls now listen Williams exec
producer
as a movie that was a movie
that's good they know what to put out in
January
it's just the right pitch
part of me is reminded I mean I know the
dances other things but you know they
got that dance in ex machina
yes I wonder if if there was any nodding
there
it's a really tight Hollywood film yeah
absolutely oh it's an actual actress
credited for Megan I guess they must
have done that they must have had an
actress just wear like one of those
creepy silicone masks of course it like
kind of looks like a generic face and
then they just animate over that puppets
and animatronics
oh
what a workshop huh
it's basically Lord of the Rings
I'm ready to talk about you yep let's do
it so what did you think that was a very
entertaining uh you know kind of
gleefully mean Thrill Ride and I
appreciate it this is you know like you
said it's one of those it's a it's a
very solid Hollywood horror Thriller and
I think it was well proportioned because
weirdly in the Afterglow of this I'm
reminded of smile just because of like
the whole like psychological trauma
aspect of that and then you know the
many people dying and and that movie had
like a a big skew to me in like half of
it felt like yeah like your your
traditional Blockbuster like haha a
bunch of scares and stuff and there's
like this surprisingly detailed like
journey of the main character
psychological State whereas here I
thought they kind of
hit the balance a little cleaner where
you know you have what is an actual
story about this mom who doesn't know
what to do uh taking care of this kid
and also is you know sort of I thought
they sold the just sort of convergence
of Life factors that make this situation
happen so you're like yeah it doesn't
seem like she's just like I gotta Pawn
this kid off of my toy but at the same
time that's pretty much what she does
and so uh yeah I thought they drew the
the
situation the emotional situation that
begets all this in a nice way and then
yeah everything else just kind of built
at a very steady and gradual Pace in
terms of Thrills and chills and you know
stomach twisting moments um yeah I
thought I thought it was really solid I
thought it was really fun uh
not too many major complaints
yeah other than maybe this yeah this is
not it didn't even really take away from
the movie there's some weird uh little
ADR moments and things like that or like
words they change or I'm like I'm pretty
sure he said kick them in the teeth and
you change just to kick them in the dick
for some reason for sure
yeah yeah I mean I think the ADR moments
are something that maybe the average
person wouldn't really give a [__] about
or really notice you know but we're more
than the average person we are Advanced
viewers we are elevated in the mind so
it makes sense why we can notice weird
editing with the audio when others like
I never picked up on such a detail it's
because you don't have the eye Nor Ear
yeah for such your unsophisticated [__]
yeah but yeah no I I think it's uh that
was I was surprised by the
extremely positive reception this movie
ended up receiving and after watching it
I totally get it it's a really really
fun movie with just the right amount of
emotional Nuance to keep you into it
um it's as as silly as it can be it's
not laughing at itself but it is having
fun with itself and it knows when it
take itself seriously and it does get
intense at times like I think by the end
I was like I don't really want what's
your name Allison what
Williams Williams yeah
um I didn't want Allison Williams to die
like I found myself going like oh I used
to be pretty bummed if she died yeah so
I don't want her to die it's got a good
Learning lesson a good heart and this uh
concept of attachment Theory and like
the doing the right thing because you
know nowadays with horror films there is
tends to be some type of traumatic angle
surrounding it and the the way they were
able to keep that alive
in a movie that is also really setting
out to just Entertain You yeah I think
is really neat you know there's some a
definite uh derivative nods to like Sam
Raimi throughout here a lot of the movie
kind of reminds me of like the child's
play reboot meets Small Soldiers yeah
with like a little bit of Orphan
sprinkled in there I haven't seen
orphans but I don't know yeah I mean
you've got this ostensible little girl
who's you know making bad things happen
so you have that sort of like I feel
like it has um
I don't know the the tone tonally
they're uh without going too far into it
tonally I think there are things that
this shares with orphan and yeah it's
like the little girl killing people and
little girl who is you know in
situations with other children blah blah
blah sure sure but yeah and and I do
appreciate that it didn't have me
thinking too much of Child's Play Even
though you certainly do it points at the
beginning I thought I was going to be
really thinking about the reboot and I'm
like yeah they both start off with like
a commercial yeah and it it took it it
didn't it didn't take like a like it
hooks you right away like it's a solid
High concept film like it's a it's just
such a solid Hollywood entertaining
horror film and
I I I can't really ask for too much more
than that you know like it it it has a
good Panache and punch to it from
beginning to end with a a lot of
Personality uh the main characters are
interesting I like how they let Katie
morph into a character who's like the
Detachment to Megan is bringing out the
worst in her when you see like oh what's
she really the important lesson you
should learn is to really feel and
grieve and also how this gen character
is uh doing so much avoidance and needs
to be there because this is them not
really knowing how to connect with each
other so they they build this outlet but
the the evolution of this Megan doll is
it it's the voice just keeps coming to
mind is like it's a really fun movie and
and you know hearing the controversy not
really controversy but sort of the upset
nature that there was the film was
supposed to be our rated R in the
beginning but then they re-shot some
[__] to make it PG-13 I didn't find
myself feeling like the scene to be
rated R it's got enough
um tonal tonal wise and it's it's sort
of it's like Grim approach uh with the
violence where it does hit like it
doesn't really need to be that gory
maybe there was like a higher body count
or some [__] but it doesn't really need
to be that gory and I I think it's like
a really solid like this is the kind of
horror movie that really could have come
out at any time of the year and it would
have worked even if it like came out in
December I would have been like yeah
there's a fun or December movie yeah
perfect for Christmas time it's about
gifting someone with this stuff you know
with this ten thousand dollar toy yeah
uh I was I was uh I was pleasantly
um surprised by how much better and I
like the approach of the characters too
I mean I only saw the trailer maybe one
time and my my mind was telling me on
memory that Jen was
Allison Williams had a daughter and then
she got her this toy and the toy started
doing [__] that's where my mind went I
didn't know
like oh just got this actual this whole
thing about like developing toys in tech
industry and the evolution of artificial
intelligence like and and that's what
her job is and like I like how her
character is someone who's very capable
and very smart uh highly intellectual
but not emotionally enough intellectual
to understand some of these decisions uh
I think that was actually really
refreshing to have that be your lead
character and to have a different kind
of dynamic and Rapport like that that
was one of the more surprising angles to
me and the thing that impressed like
that's the part that surprised me but
the thing that impressed me the most was
the execution of its pacing and its tone
to keep it feeling Lively and knowing to
not just because if it was just funny
throughout then it would have been
boring and it would have gotten
repetitive and a lot of the more uh
intense scenes would not have hit so I
thought this did a great job of making
it like a a really like yeah this is a
eyes like I want to see you kill people
yeah I want to see you do [__] I want
like this is really fun in a very
genuine way without it feeling like
they're forcing any type of emotion one
way or the other it really had a kind of
a natural flow uh throughout so I I
think it did an excellent job it's
really it's it's really impressive it's
actually really impressive they they
pulled this off in a way that's just
like yeah there's really nothing that
but wrong with the film there's very
little fat on that bone yeah yeah yeah
it's really clean it's tight it's punchy
it builds well and yeah I think it's
it's uh it's and then there are little
things like that that I'm appreciating
in hindsight of like yeah you have this
person who is
not emotionally stunted but is at least
having trouble connecting emotionally in
a real situation in their life who is
then authoring this machine that is
supposed to gather and Aggregate and
build on emotions so even in a sort of
like spiritual complementary way I feel
like aspects of that work out and and
yeah even if there are like little
things in the moment you know like
anytime you see an AI movie you're like
guys never ever talk to the AI like it's
not a person because it's just gonna
lead to the world but that's part of the
fun and I think it's you know they draw
a situation where you're able to yeah
root for Megan to rack up that body
count wreak some Havoc but you also do
want to see her go down at the end yeah
and that is also rewarding and yeah they
I think they made great use of The
Uncanny Valley and questions about again
just the more we get into the future the
more AI like right now it's all about AI
art and what are the implications of
that and AI music and they you know not
in a huge way but they bring those asp
specs in two so it feels very timely but
it you know is sort of like a pro like
as far as sci-fi goes there's almost a
Timeless nest because you do have things
like Westworld that have explored this
territory too
um so yeah this deals with that real
life conversation without it being way
down by commentary yeah of of of being
of especially with children growing up
in a world with technology of uh lack of
flat I'll call it here of a lack of
human connection and social skills
things that being glued to our phones
and iPads and whatever of how that can
create an emotional distance and make it
difficult to socialize and adapt and
you're dealing with that subject matter
here pretty much throughout the whole
film without I without the movie ever
feeling like you're preaching something
to me like I never really even thought
about it till right now that that's kind
of though the theme throughout yeah
because when they arrived there when
she's fine finally in the room with
Katie and and Gemma says that thing
about like no you have to feel this way
and they have the whole realization of
the necessity of of the counterweights
to happiness and then balancing emotions
and confronting and accepting emotions
and and that moment I was like
gracefully done because yeah I haven't
gotten the sense that this movie is just
trying to get that message across to me
and yeah they draw the mess of the
action based on that theme well enough
that yeah it feels like just the right
amount of nuance for what the movie is
and they did a great job with developing
the relationship watching everything
de-escalate and escalate with Megan and
Katie because but like I thought the
scene was brilliant with the whole you
know um comforting Megan when she's
opening up about her parents being dead
and how Megan is there to console her
like watching their relationship grow
and Beyond just having like do you know
what attachment Theory and like just
really explaining that so the audience
also knows
the when it gets to the point where
Katie is becoming this like obsessive
almost like a has this like addiction uh
to Megan and this codependency and she
is like lashing out and becoming rageful
it's believable it it it's it works it's
not something where it feels like some
you're some stupid kid you know like
yeah it's all very believable how this
kid emotionally gets there and they
provide a lot of nuance you know like
even when she like lashes out and smacks
her she's very she apologizes afterwards
like they they did a really good job on
um making making it more but but again
it's it's the right you gotta find that
right pitch where you're not overdoing
anything to the point where you're
you're trying to be more than what you
really are yeah you know yeah it it I
think it fills a few different glasses
nicely and that yeah it's it's got some
kind of you know modern commentary about
yeah it's like toy Tech and attention
addiction and things like that and then
yeah the emotional story and then yeah
just like the slashery you know sci-fi
horror Thrills yeah Megan's great I
thought like Megan the character was
really fun too I loved her Evolution I
thought it was really solid and there
were times where I'm like when is Megan
operation Opera operating right now is
she on right now like that it had me
even sometimes questioning like what's
going when is this happening and her her
like evolving into just full-blown like
I don't have to I'm not gonna [__]
anymore
I feel like no more [__] yeah I am
in control now I am the captain but also
making it of a have given Megan a motion
too where she too has the attachment
problems herself yeah uh of like when
she's talking about Gem and she's
telling her you know like I thought we
were like I really believed that with
the making character like I thought we
were friends my plan my solution is not
to kill you yeah you know I don't want
to do this you're forcing me to do this
because the prime directive necessity
States it yeah so I really I really
really liked Megan a lot as well because
she could have just been like mysterious
killer machine but it did seemed to be
imbued with a true emotional motivation
behind why she was doing anything that
she was really doing Beyond I must
protect you know like and you do watch
her evolve and like even get hurt by the
end with Katie hurting her yeah you want
I mean you watch as she grows you know a
personality and casts judgments on
people and yeah yeah like she's clearly
learned more than just facts from having
like the entire internet at her disposal
and it's one of those movies too that I
think benefits from like uh early on you
probably have certain like nitpicky
questions that you're throwing out there
just for fun that the movie I think does
actually catch up to and confront and I
think that's always a nice sign of
something like this because you know for
a movie of this variety you don't have
to go as far as they went to check off
all their different you know boxes in
terms terms of all the things the
movie's trying to do
and I appreciate that they did it seems
like they took at least enough time to
hammer out the science story enough that
you know other than like an AI robot
specialist most of us will be like cool
yeah it makes sense and then hammering
out everything on top of that you know
the horror stuff makes sense and is you
know pretty well positioned and
proportionate because it's not doing
that all the time but when it is it's
pretty intense and it's pretty freaky I
think you there's a there's a lot of I
mean they're already got the sequel and
development I think they want to release
the next year yeah and I I I feel like
they've got a lot of great room for a
variety of different sequels like
Megan's still alive the company had this
big launch that completely failed the
CEO died Megan could be like rebuild
herself she doesn't want to come back
and like seek revenge or something like
that like she's Ultron now she's in the
internet yeah she is yeah so there's a
lot of different ways uh you can you can
go with this and then just really
capitalize on what actually they thought
was the strongest suit that really
worked but you got to have Megan get
back in the doll suit and stuff because
I thought you know uh I I thought this
movie was gonna be the I didn't the
self-awareness
was not as present in the trailers to me
because this movie's not some giant
self-aware comedy but there are scenes
where it's very self-aware of what it's
doing like even the way the dance scene
went down that was constantly meme of
what everyone talked about because that
was part of the thing with the trailers
that made me go as this movie realize
that this is a joke yeah I don't know if
this movie knows it's a joke
um but even with that dancing went down
like it was funny but it was also used
in a way to taunt and intimidate and
then like manipulate like uh trick her
way over to getting that blade and stuff
like alert it was it was it's it's used
properly within context of the actual
scene itself and not just like have her
dance you know yeah yeah yeah yeah not
not we need to create a meme moment yeah
it's it's a diversion tactic I thought
it was I I was the movie the movie's
smart it's a smart solid crisp film yeah
yeah yeah it's very conscientious about
what it's doing lean as hell to you know
a surprise and um they get the payoff
with Bruce I was very happy about that a
surprise I was surprised I did not
predict okay we joked about that right
we did but I didn't think that no
they're good to come back yeah oh
they're actually gonna do this
completely forgot about the gloves and
everything yeah well and they're that's
good because they do lay out like a few
different little chekovs guns of like oh
no that's gonna come back to the view
making no maybe that'll come back to
defeat Megan you know I thought her head
might explode
she was trying to do right yeah remove
it yeah yeah yeah totally remove the
part and then I think Katie just
ultimately remembers like that's where
the brains are so she just stabs it in
the brain's smart yeah smart family
smart fam I love when single moms and
the Child live yes yeah it's a whole
genre now it is genre he made it from
Hill House to Megan and now who knows
well guys what did you think about Megan
did you enjoy it like everyone else in
the world uh leave your thoughts down
below
um are there any fun
anything that really stands out
is modeled in part off another
GLaDOS okay
some info about how they did the mega
effects with the actor
uh
okay this is the most interesting part
of this is watching us look at facts
the titles from mathrigan
he's never mentioned in the film
yeah hey who put that there
is direct nods to Child's Play 1988 sure
oh and the idea with Kurt is that's the
idea why funky was able had Rivals who
were stealing from them
there we go that's a good detail so yeah
so Megan just would have been the next
step in an already happening uh yeah
deceit or maybe Kurt actually did sell
some that's another plot thing maybe
yeah
and then or someone fights his computer
you know yeah oh man there's a lot dude
the cops confiscate his computer after
that they find it but I think Megan
would have been able to would have said
that right when she was like you sold
the secrets to me yeah that's true yeah
yeah so I guess he didn't anyway guys
mathrigan's done thank you so much for
being here be sure to like this video
subscribe what was your favorite part of
this film and I thank you to all showing
your support by following us on patreon
see all that
[Music]